hello welcome back to big mood today we
are dealing with a heavier topic it
could go heavy mm-hmm
or it could be light depending on if
you're from Mexico or not to depend on
that who's here I'm Nikki I'm TIFF I'm
just I'm Gina and we are big mood and
today is a big move today is a big
somber mood I feel like at this point
it's been a while since because we pre
require a lot of our episodes but like
Kobe recently you don't currently past
yeah I feel like it's heavy my heart
night I didn't know like how much it
would actually affect me because it's
been rough man it's been like a good
week I think cuz I feel like I didn't
really follow basketball so I don't like
it wasn't gonna affect me that much but
it really has and the entire freaking
city feels like it's under water right
now it really does and then seeing
everyone with the purple and gold like
yeah just on my way over here I saw like
a motorcycle guy he had a Lakers Jersey
and then someone else like in their car
I could see that they had a Lakers
Jersey too and I'm just like oh musses
on there scrolling marquee it says r.i.p
Kobe on it a little liquor store next to
my house says alright P Kobe and I'm
kind of like that's great but also
you're a liquor store it's a little mini
Laker store Lakers liquor store
yeah just like literally every business
in LA is full of Kobe stuff it was crazy
too because the next day after it
happened so you know how it happened on
Sunday morning on Monday Casey had a
meeting with with our business manager
and they usually they go to this cafe
that we always go to and when they got
there the lady was like closing up and
she was she was like oh yeah you know
there's like this there are other
restaurants around the city that we all
agreed like we're just gonna close and
it's you know so we heard the whole
family's yawl be mourning Kobe like for
TOB and so but then when Casey showed up
he was like oh yeah no it's cuz we were
gonna meet her but yeah we totally get
it and so she ended up bringing up a
bringing out a pot of coffee for them to
still meet outside like in the outside
seating and so every time someone was
trying to come in like Casey was
explaining to be
like oh yeah they closed because you
know just we're just sitting here people
are closing their business for Toby yeah
he really impacted a lot of the city so
it got us thinking about just like how
we've dealt with death in our own lives
and I know people have different coping
mechanisms and people have different
experiences with losing someone and I
feel like on my end it's been pretty
light I feel like well knock on wood I'm
very grateful that I've kept everyone
close to me but like I have lost a few
grandparents but they were already I was
already kind of disconnected from them
by the time they passed like my grandma
had Alzheimer's and I felt like when she
was alive but couldn't recognize me was
more painful and hurtful than when she
passed it was they lost her as she's
still here yeah to lose somebody while
they're still living is an insane
experience because it was like I had all
these memories of my grandma and she had
none of me anymore and uh to make
matters worse she thought she was super
young when she had Alzheimer's and so
she would flirt with like my brother and
my grandpa and like every cheap flirt
with everybody and she she saw me as a
threat she thought that I was gonna try
she's still another yeah and so she'd
always oh you're really pretty but she's
she she kicked me out of the house a few
times and does hurt yeah but the less I
see
and the way she would do it do like she
would clearly be talking to my grandpa
and being like I don't like her I don't
like get her out and then she'd look at
me and she'd go hi
this right in your face hi how are you
as various here but the last time I saw
her she hugged me and she said this
one's mine it's hurtful but like you
look back one time she told me that she
thought she's thought my grandpa was the
guy that owns the buildings yeah and
she's like yeah that guy he owns the
buildings he's rich but I think he wants
to have sex with me what happens when
they like see themselves in the mirror
oh that - she'd fight with the the old
lady in the mirror in the bathroom that
would steal her stuff so she would see
this old lady in the bathroom with all
of her rings on and like her jewelry and
she'd be like give those back to me
those aren't yours wow what a mindfuck
do you like yelling in the mirror yeah
do just take me out yeah Alzheimer's I
just [ __ ] let me go take me to
Switzerland or wherever they allow the
assisted suicide and just take me huh I
do not want to live through that that is
so crazy
shame I want to have like a waiver like
way in advance like yeah or they have
all those like I forgot what the form as
a do not resuscitate her like all this
other stuff but I wanted to be like
Alzheimer's immediately take me out
execute and walk to the roofer got what
I was getting execution time Steve like
surprises me and he's like you've been
standing there for 45 minutes zoning
like what like yeah it's literally been
45 minutes again is like saving you
you're like early dementia stop you sits
there like four to five he's just
exaggerating to make you seem crazy so
that you feel like you need him grainy
damn no that reminds me - so my grandpa
passed he was
he was a 70 when you pass and then uh
this is back in like 2013 12 11 hmm oh
man I can't really remember but when he
was in the hospital he had gotten like a
catheter put in which is like you know
like the tube in your urethra which is
where you and I always wondered how that
[ __ ] works and I oh dude it when they
took it out after I know it was crazy
anyway so he ends up saying like I went
to go visit him and in the hospital he's
like grabbing my hand he's like mica
your grandma told the doctor that she
told them it's her fault and I was like
what what happened and he was like your
grandma
chopped it off she doesn't want me to
ever use it she chopped it up and I was
like what are you talking about he's
like my thing it's gone it's not here
anymore Mia I can't okay feel it anymore
it's not there and I'm like Mike was so
funny he's like he's like parent like
pack panicking that his wiener got
chopped off but he said that the
catheter you can't feel it if the
catheters in is immediate I don't know
what happened but that he's so funny
that he just immediate he's like your
grandma she [ __ ] cut it off maybe he
felt pain there maybe she thought that
it was from getting beestings but no
it's crazy because in that same hospital
when I went to go visit my grandpa like
that's that's where he had passed some
time after that and this isn't TJ so you
know unless you have a lot of money you
don't get the best healthcare and and so
because he didn't have heart monitors on
cuz he had emphysema he was a smoker so
he had like lung issues and he ended up
passing from a heart attack because well
they weren't monitoring his heart but in
that same hospital recently my cousin
passed and that's because he had he had
a brain tumor and they didn't know that
he had it and it was so big that they
decided to operate on it but be again
because it's not the best health care he
didn't really recover and it was like
the most heartbreaking thing ever
because he's like a close
we're close in age so every time I'd go
to TJ he was like the sweetest he always
had the smile on his face and he
actually loved watching everything that
I was doing on YouTube and he would
always like support and he would always
show his the videos to his son to which
he left a son and and so when I went to
go see him he was like pretty much
paralyzed like a vegetable and it was
just really hard to see a family member
like that especially someone you grew up
with and like actually so yelling too
because you don't expect it oh yeah
shocking if he was 85 you'd be like okay
I get it you know but like him being so
young he's younger than me too you know
it's like you know it kind of makes you
reflect on your own own mortality too I
think that's why it's so shocking cuz
you're like oh my god can I be in the
situation where I don't normally think
that way you just expect to be 85 and
then like kick and dust you know but
like when you see someone so young it's
just so feels so weird like in your body
it feels weird to see that exactly it
was like that wasn't supposed to happen
exactly you were living in a different
reality right yeah exactly it was just I
don't know it was really rough I think
that that loss has been I think the way
I cope with with lots of family members
is um when I find out I cried out and I
kind of put it in a box I don't know if
that's me like me having dealt with it
or me not dealing with it
but that's kind of how I've dealt with
when people around me have have passed
so I don't I don't know like I kind of I
don't know how to fool you more and I
guess yeah I don't know how what how
it's supposed to feel like I I don't
know how to I know what you mean like
cuz that's kind of how I feel - or like
um like sometimes because I it's been so
long since I saw my grandma like in her
the way that I remember her it had been
ten years since I saw her healthy from
that time she passed - like the last
time I saw her healthy so in my mind
like she was already gone or like I
hadn't seen her so it was almost like I
can put her over here like she's living
in her house still over here
right cuz I already wasn't seeing her so
when she passed it was like she's still
there but then I'll have dreams where
she's her normal self again and I'll
chill hug me and I'll just start bawling
and I'll just be bawling in my dream and
like wake myself up crying and I think
it's because my body just hasn't
processed it yet and like I'm just in
denial denial denial denial and then
like the dreams make me have to confront
that I lost they say the reason why we
dream is because our that's our
subconscious dealing with our day-to-day
problems or issues or whatever but I I
completely relate to that too because
when when I was 14
I had this classmate who had died
because he was involved in like gang
affiliation stuff in Mexico know in
Downey and I was living in Mexico when I
found out yeah so when I found out like
I found out through my best friend
because we were talking on the phone
when I was out there and she tells me
like yeah Danny Paz like he got killed
and I'm like what like that was the
first death I had ever dealt with and
like my whole world like it was like it
was [ __ ] crazy I just could not wrap
my head around that this child got
killed and I was just it was so crazy
but that night I was crying so much and
I ended up dreaming of Danny and he when
he popped in my dream it was like heaven
and clouds and stuff and he was telling
me like like TIFF it's okay like I'm
good don't worry like I'm in a good
place like don't worry about me and I
ended up getting sleep paralysis because
I was yeah so when my eyes were closed I
saw him and I opened my eyes and I
couldn't move but I saw the ceiling of
the room that I was in and I was just
like what is happening right now and so
I closed my eyes and I see Danny and I'm
trying to tell him like I guess for me
and I felt like it was I could still
save him like I was back in time and I
was trying to prevent his death and I
telling him like no don't go out and
like stay in your house like this Dave
just stay in your house and but he was
telling
it's okay I'm gone and you can let go
it's alright and I just for many years
like I really felt strongly like that
was Danny spirit like yeah you he legit
visited me and put me at ease you know
that's what happened to me too so the
first person I ever lost when I was like
14 years old it was my cousin Simon and
he was it was the four of us that grew
up together every summer we spent here
in LA I would come from Northern
California to LA and it was me Simon
Nancy sandy it was for cousins he was
the only boy and like he used to like
play video games and we would watch him
he'd name all the characters after us
and stuff it was really cute and then so
when I was 14 I got a call from my mom
she's like hey um he was not 18 19 19
she was like hey so Simon passed away
he was riding a motorcycle which to this
day I am very much against my god
seriously and these two cars are racing
and one of them clipped him and took off
and so he flew off landed on top of
another car and he was pretty much a
vegetable and they had to pull the plug
on him and then it was really weird so I
remember my mom telling me and I was
just like oh okay and then I just sat
there like all right no how old are you
in this happy 14 and this is like my
first loss and then it wasn't till like
30 minutes later it when I was sitting I
was like oh [ __ ] wait no this is someone
that I'm like I spent a lot of time with
I think this is like my childhood
growing up like water fights in the
summer and walking to Target and stuff
you know and then that's when I [ __ ]
just cried and I lost my mind and then I
called my mom back and then a part of me
felt bad like I'm sorry I didn't cry
earlier when you told me cuz I didn't
know how to react and this time I called
her and I was crying I was a mom I have
to go to that funeral so she takes me
down to Southern California we go to the
funeral and that's when I'm like crying
a lot
then we come back here and then in like
a week or two I left I was living with
my dad's side of the family at the time
and I left him because I [ __ ] hated
them and then I moved in with my mom and
then I remember so in Chinese tradition
you burn things for them to so that they
can have it in the afterlife right so
we'd have like paper Mercedes model
and paper money and like stuff like
that's a Chinese tradition and thinking
about that I wrote a letter to Simon and
then I burned it for him and then I
remember coming home from school one day
and I just stood in front of my bed and
I just like fell forward and I fall
asleep like I was in the middle of
changing into my at-home clothes and in
the middle of it I just fell forward I
just fell asleep completely uh-huh yeah
and then I dreamt that I was in like a
big white room I was like in one corner
and there was a door in that corner and
the diagonal side and then Simon walked
in and then like I ran to him was I holy
[ __ ] dude what's up and then like I
hugged him and then I felt his heart
beat or I heard his heartbeat and then I
remember feeling his arm use warm like
he just felt normal and I looked up at
him I was like what does this mean like
does it mean that you're alive or
something and he looked at me he goes
yeah I'm okay
like don't worry like you know what to
worry anymore I'm good like don't cry
anymore okay
and I'm like okay and then he
disappeared then I just woke up and I
ran to my mom's rooms like a bomb I'm
just so excited and like I told her what
happened and then from that point on I
just felt like okay and I really felt
like Simon came to visit me because I
was having such a hard time dealing with
my first death and then like years later
when I was like 23 I think I told you
guys a story about how I went to go
speak to a medium mm-hmm and I don't
really believe in [ __ ] like that but
then like wow sitting there he goes hey
there's someone here that wants to talk
to you he's like a teenage boy and like
he died in public and it was like a
really tragic death and by the time the
ambulances came he was already dead and
I was just like okay and I knew it was
buddy's mom I know and then I didn't
want to say who it was because I didn't
want like this is a [ __ ] yeah you don't
want him to like grab any details in
like yeah
and then so he's like yeah and he said
that him and his dad had a little
nickname for you when you were a kid
like little piggy and I was like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and I just like lost my
[ __ ] because they used to call me Chula
which in Cantonese mean piggy vanishes
Toula oh really like no no Chula is like
cute girl oh okay that's cute okay I
prefer that one said so I was just like
and I went into like [ __ ] full like
panic Moto's what do you mean where's
this guy at he
so he's from the UK he's friends with my
hair stylist and he's like a celebrity
medium like he's like Mickey Rourke's
like main medium they fly him out all
the time jay-z yeah there's no way he
would have known this no way I've never
spoken about Simon and he goes yeah that
was a nickname he gave you and also um
so when he died you wrote him a letter
didn't you I was like whoa yes he goes
he just wanted you to know that he read
the letter because he was standing right
next to you when you wrote oh my gosh
creepy yeah and then he's like and one
of your cousins one of the girls had a
dog and that was my cousin Nancy who had
a Rottweiler that passed away and he's
like can you tell her that you know the
dogs up here with him and he's perfectly
fine they hang out together and it's
chill and that's what I told my cousin
and she started crying and he goes and
also he wants to pass on a message tell
his brothers and sisters
Congrats on the baby Congrats in the new
house and tell mom and dad to take down
the pictures of him there's way too many
in the house so afterwards I called up
his sister I'm like hey is someone
pregnant but she goes yeah why it's like
who she you might want to sit down for
this one
and I told her what's like I'm like did
someone buy a house she's like yeah his
brother bought a house I was like oh
[ __ ] so here's what happened and they
she's like bawling her eyes out and like
gee have a lot of pictures of him in the
house she's like yeah I'm like okay you
need you to take a few down and make
some kind of uncomfortable and they just
it was it was really fun Wow seemed like
two people that I've known that passed
away down to like nicknames that they've
given me it's [ __ ] scary and then um
he like stopped in the middle of reading
and was like do you have like a woman
that passed away and then I was like no
like anyone that's ever passed away was
just a male and he goes is there someone
here by the name of Lorelai and it's one
of the because we were doing a reading
it's a um it's a soul it's a hair salon
but on the other side there's a cafe
connected to it and he's like is there
someone in Laurel I'm like yep that's
actually the hair stylist over there he
goes okay I'll be right back and he went
over to that side to the salon he goes
hey Lorelai and then she said yeah he's
like do you have a sister she's like yes
but he's like yes she passed away didn't
she she's here and she wants to talk to
you and Lorelai just dropped her comb
and just like [ __ ] cried too
it was terrifying dude whoa really like
it felt good yeah closure from it yeah
and then he was also like hey so
whatever you want to do in the future
I suggest that you go into hosting like
hosting a show this is something no I'm
crazy I like I always see those ones on
TV and they seem like such fraudsters
that I'd be so curious to me a real
person in like cuz I don't really
believe any of that stuff like you know
when my mom passed away I had a similar
experience with the dreaming stuff so
like I was in and out of sleep the
morning I was supposed to supposed to be
like I supposed to visit her that last
day I already knew she was like in a
kind of an induced coma or whatever so I
knew she didn't have much time left
actually alive but she was already
pretty much gone but then I was in and
out of sleep that morning before I was
posed to go back to the hospital and I
dreamt of her and she was kind of like
I'm okay blah blah blah like telling me
that kind of stuff
and then by the time I got ready to go
to the hospital like she had already
passed I kind of felt like she was
telling me in my sleep like it's okay
like you didn't make it in time but it's
still okay
but I remember the night before and this
is the weird supernatural stuff that I
had like never believed in before until
I kind of saw it with my own eyes and I
was like today am I seeing things
because I've always been such a science
person so it was so weird but as I was
sitting there my mom at one point she
was on a breathing machine and I was
like maybe it's just the breathing
machine I don't know but I was watching
her and I was talking to her and I was
crying and doing all this stuff and then
at one point this like white mist like
left her mouth and shot into the room
almost like I was like was that her
[ __ ] leaving her body I swear to god
it was the creepiest [ __ ] ever I almost
had a panic attack because I was sitting
there just holding my mom as she was
like in a coma and all of a sudden this
white like it was just like went into
the air and I was just like what the
actual [ __ ] like that scared the [ __ ]
out of me you know what else is white
and feels really misty and Kobe
I love like a cloud worst transitions
ever you have like my spirit I wonder
what the spirits feel like when you're
just hanging out the clouds up there you
can feel it so no but seriously Buffy
makes the world's most comfortable
bedding ever everything is made from
ultra smooth eucalyptus fiber that feels
softer than cotton it's just like I
don't even it's incredible I'd even know
how how it's an earthly substance but
you close Lulla a eucalyptus fiber is
breathable and cool to the touch to help
maintain the ideal sleeping temperature
and feel cozy without overheating so
I'll use sweaters all you heathens that
sweat in your sleep me and I making all
those sheets all yellow oh you don't
have to do that if you have a puffy
comforter keeps it cool at night
customers love Buffy their products have
almost 20,000 five-star reviews I'm one
of those plus an overall average rating
of 4.6 stars believe the hype I cannot
imagine another night in a different
comforter because I love my Buffett
comforter so much but I haven't been
able to sleep in my bed the same since
sleeping in yours right with the Buffy
sheets and everything hover dude it's
got everything I mean just can't even
get a [ __ ] blanket not on those other
things separately okay I do have the
buffy comforter Brite put it in a
different duvet cover oh it's not like
the premium experience that nikki is
yeah I gotta get the do make the premium
experience is the [ __ ] so Buffy offers a
free trial you can try a comforter in
your own bed for free if you don't love
it you can return it at no cost for $20
off your Buffy comforter visit Buffy CO
and inter mood once again that's $20 off
your Buffy comforter visit Buffy CO and
enter mood mm-hmm
you know what else is great saving money
yeah right do you guys do a lot of
online shopping hell yeah only shop
online I think only when I'm sad which
is all the time
so I'm sure you guys have tried this
right honey you know tried honey who've
heard it I have the app on my phone oh
yeah so do I so honey is a free online
shopping tool that saves you money
online so honey automatically finds the
best promo codes and applies them to
your cart so when you're shopping on one
of your favorite sites like Target Best
Buy Sephora Macy's when you check out
this little box drops down and all you
have to do is click apply coupons you
wait a few seconds for it to scan for
every promo code on the internet and
then that's when you see the prices drop
so it's a it's an extension that you can
add to your browser and so for me
personally I've been loving this I also
do a lot of online shopping and it saves
me so much money so the last time I
think I was shopping at Victoria's
Secret to get some more wardrobe for our
set yeah and it legit saves me like $50
it was insane today lucky that day yeah
I did so honey has found it's over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings so not using honey is
literally passing up free money it's
free to use and installs in just two
clicks so get honey for free at join
honey dot-com / mood that's join honey
calm / mood save that money even monies
say your mom's your vaped you saw her
sow yeah and I immediately googled that
well after I calmed down I think it was
like the next day I googled it and I was
like has anyone seen like a white mist
leave a person like as they're dying and
there was other people that were talking
about it so I don't know if that's some
physiological thing maybe a doctor some
sort of like buddies yeah yeah something
but I was just like in the moment it
made me feel like I watched her spirit
leave her body which is so [ __ ] weird
and then I you know kind of I sort of
left shortly thereafter cuz I was like I
think she's gone like I don't know it
was just this weird feeling like I could
have just been reacting to something
that's totally natural but yeah that
that was one of the first times I felt
like whoa is the spirit actually real
because I've always kind of been this
sort of like skeptic like science like
Oh like consciousness is just like
whatever
like I don't believe in heaven or hell
or any of this other stuff but then at
that moment I was like well this is
weird I'm just an agnostic we're like I
guess really kind of like that too yeah
like I am very comfortable admitting
that you know like I don't know yeah I'm
open to anything yeah nothing's been
proven or disproven or anything so if
you were like if there became a solid
proof that's like there is zero
afterlife and everybody just dies and
then you go into the earth and that's it
then I'd be like okay it's cool people
were like oh there's solid proof that
you go to this other place on my alright
roll with any of it for me like I feel
like because of like the scientific
foundings of the fact that there is
energy mm-hmm that's a fact and that
were made energy and we're made of
energy like to me is just really hard to
believe that that energy just disappears
it it's gonna go somewhere I don't know
where and there also scientists that
have like had like a like died like
technically their heart stopped for like
a couple minutes or whatever and they
claim to have seen something beyond like
some sort of after place like a chemical
reaction that could be explained like
science I'd like to know but just like
brain brain chemical reactions think of
it as like I don't know I'm very much on
the fence because I'm a very like
sciency person too and I didn't believe
in it and and then like when I went to
that guys all right yeah that mean it
really throws a wrench and yeah like I
would kind of want to experience that
myself because that would really change
my mind just like if he could tell me
about something that I haven't told
anyone because I've lost about five
family members and then one friend from
high school and if he just brought up
like some [ __ ] that I've never said on
camera I would be like oh my god
actually solidifies my under like my
beliefs or whatever because I do feel
like that energy is somewhere and so he
just he's learned how to tap into the
energy I don't know I really feel like
our spirits our energy that still is
gonna live somewhere in this university
I learned them like [ __ ] just hanging
out somewhere
I could probably be omnipresent we're
like they're not just like literally
hanging out like how we are in our realm
you're here you can't be there in the
it's in the [ __ ] hard drive somewhere
yeah [ __ ] happily that's so fake
that's so stupid but then at the same
time like there's histories and stories
of this like dating all the way back to
like all generations every generator and
I'm sorry every civilization had stories
of like ghosts and spirits and stuff
like that so it's like if it's been
around for that long you know it has I
can't go down that road though cuz I'm
always like well people were just dumb
there weren't people who are dumb - yeah
like they didn't know like the that the
earth was round and they didn't know
like this what stars were and they
didn't know like all this other stuff so
for me to think even with religion to
know that people like oh well it's been
around for a thousand years and like I
don't even label it as dumb either I
would just label it as like that was
their interpretation of what we now know
just a different interpretation because
things that we now interpret today like
thousands of years ago today they're
gonna look at us like oh they
interpreted it that way but this is how
we now interpret this stuff yeah that's
true yeah and then I've also a part of
me like my it's weird sometimes I feel
like [ __ ] for it and then another like
and then I realize that this is probably
how I just deal with death and I don't
like to visit it I don't visit graves
never like can enjoy you ever have you
there exactly like when Simon passed
away this was like [ __ ] when I was
like 14 I've only visited once and I
never went back and a part of me feels
like am i [ __ ] personally no here no
that's just their their body or like the
earthly embodiment and then like that's
really their their spirit their soul or
whatever you want to call it like that
that they're not there with yet body so
that I don't think that means anything
cuz like my when my mom passed away we
got her cremated because um she didn't
have any like life insurance or anything
like that and I couldn't afford a $5,000
burial or whatever so we had to get her
cremated but I had the her ashes sent to
my dad's house and I was supposed to go
back to my dad's house to spread the
ashes and I was like this is this gonna
be my final thing like I just kind of
spent my life like trying to
to like be with her as best as I could
and I was the only one there when she
passed away and I'm gonna be the one
there to spread her ashes and all that I
could never do it I literally never did
it hurt her ashes sat at my dad's house
for like six months because he was
waiting for me to come back to do it and
I just could never do it and then
finally I went back I spent like a week
with my dad we did all this stuff and I
still was I just still couldn't do it
and then so I just finally said like can
you do it for me like I don't think he
even wanted to either but he did it for
me and so I was just like oh thank God
but then I'm like I don't feel like I'm
a bad person because I couldn't you
don't you know you're saying like once
like visiting a cemetery like that's
like there remains like that like you're
saying like there's like no soul there
or anything left that's kind of I feel
and I'm sorry if I'm gonna offend anyone
I hope I don't this is just my personal
beliefs that's kind of how I feel about
religion and like certain like holy like
churches or whatever it is like I
personally do not believe that you need
to go to a building to connect to the
higher or whatever that you believe in
because for me I I guess I'm an agnostic
to I don't know want to label it but I
do believe there's a like a higher being
out there and it could be the just a
simple fact that it's the universe or
whatever it is I I don't I don't know if
it's like a single presence or whatever
but if there is I don't believe that I
can't connect to it like to that
whatever I need so whenever I know just
on your own yeah talking about you don't
need to go to like a priest to confess
your sin exactly Catholics do or go to
church every Sunday or whatever yeah I
mean I'm not yeah you know I'm just
saying personally I don't believe that
you have to physically go somewhere you
know I feel like a dark ass energy
around a lot of churches and I think
it's just cuz a lot of people like feel
so guilty and like they're sinners and
stuff when they go in there I don't know
what it is but it feels like just a
heavy energy for most churches like say
for never felt like better energies yeah
yeah I remember um my ex-boyfriend he
was like a very religious guy and like
this is like when we were we were like
he was gonna propose and we were like
getting really serious into it and he
was just like it would mean a lot to me
if like you went to church with me
and I'm like all right cool you know
let's go check it out and it was just
like we went to this church I like for
me I don't believe in building very
luxurious houses of worship for your god
like that's just so that's what it is
houses a question to me you know um so
like I don't I don't believe in
monuments like that and then so we went
to the church I was like okay cool um
when I listen to this guy speak for a
little bit but it wasn't it was a guy
giving like a sermon or some [ __ ] in a
remote place and they're all watching it
on TVs oh so I'm like you guys went to
this big-ass building to watch TV
everybody went to this club because the
people were with they wanted to see this
DJ perform and they were like headlining
it like this DJ's gonna be there but we
get there you have to pay to go into
this club to see this DJ and it's just a
TV screen yeah so sitting there I'm just
looking around all these people like you
guys do realize you're [ __ ] watching
someone on TV right like we could have
done this at home I will my house up at
7:00 a.m. and put on a cardigan for his
[ __ ] you know so like it's just I
couldn't I couldn't do it like I I like
the aspect of religion in a way where
people use it to guide themselves and
you know if it keeps them going then
great it provides organization yeah
that's cool yeah and I also think that
like humans naturally want to be part of
something bigger than themselves and
like they feel more purpose in that and
for people that haven't found that
elsewhere a lot of times churches or
religions will be that for them which is
something that's that's an aspect I
really do like what I don't like is when
people use it to feel better than other
people yeah like if you're not in this
in my group then you're okay you're yeah
you're terrible Cinnabons they're
[ __ ] disgusting here and nobody likes
it um but so for me when otherway that i
deal with death is also um since I'm not
very religious person I feel like I'm
very lucky like yeah they passed away
but now I have like a spirit watching
over me that really cares for me you
know a little guardian angels yeah
actually give a [ __ ] about me like you
know it's not like some random general
do that the signs like 700
this random angel yeah public defender I
think that guy to your friends are like
y'all want to talk to my friend he's
like nanana just $5 cover like um so
yeah like it's cool like I have like
this dude that's hanging out there and
do you ever speak to people who you lost
all the time so what well for me so till
this day I struggle with like if I were
to draw it like if I'm driving and I
Drive past an accident and it happens to
me a motorcycle I must pull over I will
have a full-blown panic attack and I
have to call one of the cousins that we
grew up with and just like well I'm just
like cry you know like I don't like
motorcycles and then so when that
happens I call my cousin's and then I
sit there and I can't have a
conversation with Simon and it's just
like dude oh my god that was really
shitty I really wish I didn't see that
you know or like there are times when
I'm just when something's going wrong
and I don't necessarily pray but I do
talk to Simon like a dude you know make
this pregnancy test negative next time
it won't happen dude sorry you know the
things that freaked me out the most and
this is also along the same vein of like
me just not being able to deal with
death is like when I just like there's
been a couple people were like they were
classmates or co-workers that I haven't
seen in a few years but one that really
[ __ ] me up last month was like who's
getting ready for the holidays right and
like everyone's got their Facebook
pictures and stuff Allah Day stuff and
this one girl from my high school that I
also worked with she was pregnant and
she was like so excited to have this
baby and she's posting all these
pictures and she was due around
Christmas time and she was like finally
I'm gonna get to be a mom and she passed
away giving birth
that never happens to like I mean right
and yeah were to happen to someone that
like I actually know cuz I saw the
stories before and I've actually like
had some people like I followed like a
bunch of random fans back in the day and
like there was one fan that had the his
wife passed away during childbirth and
it really freaked me out and I followed
their story because I was just so
freaked out by that that how can you
like be expecting something so happy and
precious and then you you have the worst
day of your life instead of the best day
of your life and and you lose everyone
close to you and then yeah so then but
it never happened to someone that I
actually knew and so then for it to
happen to this girl who it's not like we
talked every day or anything but like
acquaintance you know I spent a lot of
time with her when I worked with her and
so I feel like she's fresh in my mind
like I know her and then she's all
excited celebrating one day and then the
next day there they're like posting
memorial service things and I'm like wow
to feel like that like the husband you
know feeling like you're about to have
this family and then you lose your whole
family way she lost the baby too yeah
well actually no that was that case she
the baby got saved but he lost her but
yeah it was just it's just crazy like
you could lose like you're your partner
I know even like one person who ever
dies there I'm like well that's enough
for me I'm not gonna have a baby you
know it's crazy ever since I was a
little kid like I always felt like I was
gonna die young and what are you saying
that yeah I felt that too
and I remember thinking like when I
found out I was pregnant I'm like oh I
guess this is how I go giving birth
straight I actually like had these like
yeah I kind of felt that too that's
weird I wonder if it's like a sign of
just depression or something in a child
he's like I knew that and I knew some
friends to like they would always be
like I feel like I'm gonna die young and
I'm like yeah me too I actually have the
answer cuz my therapist will know what
it is though so I told her this right um
and she says when people have
experienced a lot of trauma and a lot of
pain and they're they're really
depressed it they cannot see a future
see themselves in the future because
they're there already so like so down in
their own hole that they can't ever
imagine getting out of it so then that's
how I that's actually the way my
therapist told me like you know what
you're good because I finally told her
in the last session we had was she had
she asked me well how do I envision my
future now and I told her I'm like I can
really see myself with gray hair playing
with my grandkids you're still blue blue
playing with my grandkids at the park
and I was bawling because I'm like I
have never visualized that ever for
myself like I could see Isaac like as an
older man with his kids and I'm like and
I just broke down and rose she had sex
concern for myself because I still like
I think I don't make goals too far in
the future and then I think the thought
of children also seems weird I'm like
I'm not gonna be here for that or like I
never really think like oh I'd never
picture myself being old or like you
know I just don't see beyond like 40 for
some reason it's super weird so I don't
really think beyond that yeah I said so
I must still have to how do you feel
about like would you ever you guys ever
think about your own death like yeah if
I had the choice to know what I would do
I would love that
really people are like scared like no I
don't know yeah we don't want to know I
would love to know cuz then I know how
like you know how long you have exactly
and I won't waste time like if you told
me [ __ ] you're gonna die next week I'm
gonna take care of what also if you also
had like 40 more years and you can do it
okay well actually let me go ahead and
like do like plan all these things out
like I don't need to dude you know that
that actually reminds me um with this
whole Kobe passing I two nights ago I
didn't go to sleep till 3:00 in the
morning because I got sucked into
Vanessa and Kobe's Instagram page and I
was just like looking at all their posts
and I was just crying and then like I
could see in on Vanessa's page that she
posted this video of them celebrating
the new years for 2020 and like they
were just so happy and they were kissing
and I was just like oh my god Mauro's
never promise exactly a president in how
many days like you know in less than a
month you're gonna be gone like that's
so it's just in it for GG - I'm seeing
her like growing up like a 13 year old
did her entire future ahead of her and I
just yeah and like seeing like the posts
getting closer and closer like what you
know you know yeah I think I'm like I
don't want to die I'm like super afraid
of dying I think that's why I have like
such a like a fierce reaction to flying
because I I feel like I'm gonna die when
I'm in an airplane and I don't want to
die so I'm like I the depression part of
it's weird because I'm like I sometimes
I like I said I don't see a future like
I don't make plans I don't have goals I
don't think too far ahead cuz like I
just don't have that much like ABC or
anything yeah I just kind of face to
black but then when death is imminent or
feels them in it I'm scared as [ __ ] like
I don't wanna die true because for me
when I think about it like so I have
these like random moments and throughout
my life that this intense realization
that there's one day I will be gone I
was tired right it feels so heavy and
like it's just everything goes like you
know like oh my god I'm gonna die one
day
when I have those moments I get really
really really scared but outside of
those moments and I think about me dying
I'm like well then that's gonna be my
time and I think I'll be okay I could be
okay with it but then I get this moment
so I'm like no wait I'm not yeah I feel
like I'm not afraid of death unless it's
a freak accident like on the plane or
like during childhood I feel like I'm
not afraid of death I just don't like
not being in control so maybe it's
because of my grandma having Alzheimer's
or whatever but I feel like I would
prefer the planned suicide thing where
like when you're like when you first
start to lose your mind because the the
scariest thing is like not having Steve
in the future like if he passes before
me or something like that like I can't
imagine living without him and I also
just don't want to lose my mind or
mental faculties
trapped in your mind is scary yeah and
then like if I'm like paralyzed yes yeah
yeah I would just rather be like alright
I feel like everything's kind of
deteriorating if I have kids I'll be
like you all have like two months with
me and then we're gonna do it on this
day on this time I read about these two
I think there were scientists either
scientists or doctors they were like
really really smart people these two
couple this couple and they did that and
it was the article was about their kids
talking about their experience with it
that like from a young age they told
them that that was how it was gonna go
down and to like just mentally prepare
for that like how he was gonna happen
that that when they started losing their
minds like cuz they would do crossword
puzzles every morning they would do
mental games and stuff and when they
first started thinking that they were
losing their minds like um they weren't
as sharp anymore disease or something I
knew that that was coming yeah like well
no no they didn't have a disease but
just you know as you aged you're you
just deteriorate like mentally
physically everything and so they were
like yeah as soon as we start to
recognize that with each other we just
have a pact that we'll plan a day while
we still have all of like most of our
mind intact and we'll have one last
dinner with all of you and we're just
gonna take this pill and and go like
what they're not gonna tell them when
they're doing it they're just kind of
like this nice I told them they're not
gonna tell them win like the day of no
yes watch midsummer no it's a new year
wait it's a recent movie so they had I
guess like that movie I think it was
Sweden but yeah they go to another
country in Europe I think it was Sweden
and they go into like this really really
really remote village where it's like
pretty much like a cult
it's how they paint it but the way that
they end their life is that once they
reach a certain age they jump off a
cliff you don't know they don't die then
they throw a boulder I'm like let me
just take a pill to make sure they're
dead why would you do this type of death
because they paint it as if this is like
a type of village has been around for
many centuries like this just
there that's just their tradition like
what I think of videogames I'm like I'm
eating those berries I don't want to die
by it like a sword or like a soul eater
yeah I'm like I mean those berries
immediately felt like I don't I don't
want I don't like not being in control
of how it's gonna go down yeah that's
how I am like [ __ ] and you know like I
can't survive if I can't get delivery
yeah if I can't get regular everyday
things like door - yeah door - I would
die if I couldn't have it yeah I mean if
there's like a zombie - I'm down I
suppose it lasts a little bit longer but
in the apocalypse there is no door - and
what does door - you ask it's a food
delivery service and it has something
for every lifestyle whether you're still
alive or honest or your zombie so you
can order pickup and pass a line if you
want to or they can deliver it to your
house door - brings all of America's
flavors to your door so if you're lazy
piece of [ __ ] like me you can order food
that brings it directly to the flavors
all the flavors not only use your
favorite pizza drawing already on door -
but they're over 310,000 Jesus Christ
three hundred ten thousand restaurants
partners four thousand cities you're
gonna find your favorite for sure yes
that many cities come on with
door-to-door delivery in all 50 US
states where Thor Eagle Canada and
Australia you can order your local go to
choose from your favorite national
restaurants like Chipotle Wendy's
chick-fil-a and the chick dude I love
cooking letter Cheesecake Factory closer
last week oh me too yeah we couldn't
order to our houses could've been a
phone call over door - you guys what
door - you'll never have to worry about
your next meal so now our listeners can
get five dull hairs off their first
order of 15 dollars or more when you
download the door - app and enter the
promo code
big mood that's one word that's five
dollars off your first order when you
the door - app in the App Store and
enter promo code big moving mood for
five dollars often after you eat you get
pretty sleepy yeah and I want to relax a
little bit oh yeah or if you're just
thinking about death and you're having
an anxiety attack you really don't know
how to sleep because you've just gone
down the rabbit hole of existentialism
you can download the calm a p-- and just
let yourself relax a little bit yep I've
actually had the comm app for probably
three years now so I've seen it go
through all of its little upgrades and
all the things that they have and my
favorite thing is the master classes
that they have there are some little
lectures on things like healthy habits
getting a good night's sleep just
different things about productivity some
little things to help you out but you
know the main point of the app is they
have a ton of meditations they have
sleep stories they like how much to go
that are relaxed and you go there to get
lectured the voices are so really call
me hot for teacher I am hot for teacher
there's a lot of women on there too the
mug there's this women teachers - Nicki
gosh you could like you could be hot for
women teachers calm is the number one
app for sleep relaxation and meditation
they have sleep stories which are like
bedtime stories for adults if you hadn't
figured that out yet they also have
soothing music this I actually like this
one - I always download or listen to the
the piano ones cuz those make me fall
asleep really well but they have
soothing music from artists like Sam
Smith mmm we all love Sam Smith does he
sing - I wonder the ones with singing I
think ours also I don't know if I'm
wrong or not but I think I saw some with
Mobe on there - I was like I don't know
I could be wrong but anyways um they
have some breathing exercises and all
kinds of stuff on there so if you go to
calm CLM dot-com zom slash mood you'll
get a limited time offer of 40% off of a
premium subscription which includes
hundreds of hours of ethyl yeah that's
almost half off that's it that's a great
promo over 60 million people already
used comm join today and accomplish our
goals tomorrow for listeners of
show again they're offering a special
limited time promotion 40% off a comprar
Miam subscription at calm calm / mood
that's 40% off of unlimited access to
their entire library and they have all
kinds of stuff
calm dot-com / mood get lectured today
yes and alarm calm the app and it was
April Fool's Day it will change to clam
calm and it's just all clam you would
change it to make it calm back home
we'll just sounds of clams all clams
calm hi oh my gosh have you seen that
okay this is totally off topic but have
you seen those videos of the Asian girls
like the muck bonkers yeah but they're
eating those clams that look like big
long kind of and then they bite it and
then I saw that it popped up in my
explore page cuz you look at it like
yeah I probably liked it this girl like
it picks up this huge clam and it's like
hanging out of the shell and she bites
it it looks like a penis and then it
squirts all over her face and she's like
purposely in those clicks yeah dude this
one entire conversation sounds like when
you fall asleep at a sleepover and then
there's like two people talking about
existence and life dude I don't have a
sleepover so you can actually experience
travel and they had a slumber party
and I had a plan who's wanted a tarot
card reading once know what palm reading
tarot card card reading I want to do a
medium the - yeah I've definitely done
tarot cards I used to go to this one
girl every year just guys like a funnier
thing to see like what's my you're gonna
be like or whatever and the reason I
went to the same person every time is
because sometimes would be dead on and I
don't necessarily I don't really think
like oh they can tell me my future
it was more of a fun thing you're like
see like they get anything right but she
actually like predicted Steve one time
like when I was single and like she
described him exactly and and just also
described his energy as being like a
really protective energy and like he's
exactly like that and she kind of said
like the the month that he would be
there and the time it would happen and
it happened exactly the way she said but
she didn't say his name and she was like
it's someone that you know already and I
was like [ __ ] and I was like I was
looking at my list friends list on
Facebook but I didn't think of him
because he was in a relationship at that
time so he was off the list I was
looking at all the single dudes and I
was like you're like I don't know I'm so
bad you know what stops me from going is
all the stories you hear about how they
like get your money or they'll they'll
like find ways to like get you to keep
paying money or they'll threaten you in
some way and I'm like man I don't know
these gangster I don't invite it into my
life because I don't know how the ones
with like the signs on their lawn and
stuff thank you little like one square
box with it's because they they get
those like little old ladies in there
they get their purses and then they keep
paying and thousands of dollars every
month because they tell them oh if you
don't give me money I don't know how
they can afford corner lot they got
celebrities too yeah yeah you know that
one time that I did the tarot card
reading she told me that at the time
there were these two guys in my life one
is like lighter skin and the other was
darker skin and they had the same name
and I was like what the hell how did you
know it was true because I at that time
I really was talking to two guys and she
ends up telling me like you're gonna end
she's like you your heart wants to go
with the lighter skin guy but you're
gonna actually end up with the darker
skin guy you're not going to be really
happy and I was like what but I look cuz
I was like thinking about this and I'm
like nah this is done the same true oh
and then the last thing she told me was
that the third the third love in your
life is gonna bro it's gonna be
oh yeah I'm wearing it too by the way
anyway um it's gonna be the guy that you
you marry so I'm like really like she
said all these things and it's now
subconscious and you make it happen
unconscious exactly what I have wanted
to believe all along but deep down
inside that part of me that I can't
really control and it's like I do
believe but like you don't want to
believe yeah but um yeah it was true cuz
the darker skin do - ended up being
Isaac's dad and the lighter skinned dude
was like the one that got away like for
many years like I kind of didn't get
over that guy and and then yeah like
sure enough the third love that I've had
was Casey like he was the third person
in my life that I was very serious with
and we got married so I'm like yeah I
don't know if it's really like spot-on
you know so you can't control Casey too
so it's kind of interesting that you did
but you know as opposed to so Casey and
I started talking in May right may 20
2012 that Halloween I had a a house
party and I got so drunk and for some
reason we ended up in the bathroom I
think I was like fixing something I'm a
makeup or something but I was pretty
wasted and like I just by then I think I
already knew I don't know if we yeah we
had already told each other we loved
each other and I was started telling him
about this like this tarot card reader
person I'm like you know what's crazy
you're the third guy in my life like
since she said that and did it and I'll
just have to marry me no I didn't think
that but I was just like wouldn't it be
crazy if like that was true and like
we'd end up marrying and then he told me
later on like years later that like me
saying that kind of freaked him out but
god I'm excited because he like he
wanted that to be true to life yeah that
[ __ ] hired her Dean Chinese auntie I
think I got you baby Mexican lady you
style alright he like wanted it planted
it all yeah even before I got pregnant
with Isaac yeah
crazy was spying on you from the across
the street here's a neighbor damn yeah
that was like the closest thing I had
there was this other one to where I had
this coworker at a hospital that I
worked at and she says she said that she
could read people's palms and then so
she ends up I mean this one is I think
is complete [ __ ] but whatever we'll
see but she ended up saying like oh yeah
I could see your son in my palm for some
reason she could see my son's future and
she said that my son is gonna be really
handsome and have all these ladies on
him and that he's gonna be making lots
of money and be very successful and I'm
like okay Larry exactly and I'm like
he's gonna be a banker and he's gonna
work at this Bank on this street but
just in case it does happen I said to
care for Thea do I feel like for an
episode like a youtube type style video
we should bring in a medium or like a
tarot card readers yeah start screaming
yeah let's have a slumber party yeah I'm
like soothing about those is like what
if like I'm in a relationship ready and
she goes yeah that's not the ones I know
you like the concepted in your brain in
your brain yeah it actually did happen
to me so I was like really in love with
back when I was with my ex it was the
same girl like but there was the year
before she was talking abouts to you so
0-4 I was with my ex and I was really in
love with him super in love but I felt
hurt constantly like he would always do
mindfuck games and I couldn't like quite
prove it and like I felt very like he
was gaslighting me all the time and like
I just felt like like I I I knew he was
it was kind of toxic but I couldn't stop
loving him so I'm like we're supposed to
be together then and she told me that
she's like it was the same thing so I
wanted her to say you guys are meant to
be together and you're just working
through this or whatever but she goes
alright you're not supposed to be with
this guy like like forever but you're
supposed to be with him for at least
another year whoa and through this year
you're going to hit like the lowest lows
and the high
heis and what it's gonna do is like
deepen your emotional capabilities like
like you'll feel depths of emotion that
you've never felt before and you'll be
able to use that in your future like for
your path like it's meant to be for your
path like you're supposed to be able to
pull from these emotional depths to help
other people with and I was like what
the [ __ ]
so I'm not gonna be with him and break
up in here and I was like set on proving
her wrong that like of course we're
gonna be together like because we have
these crazy fights and then we make up
and I feel like he got me more than any
other person and I'm like there's no way
I'm supposed to be with anyone else and
and then like yeah like a year later
like I find out he's cheating on me
which is like the last straw he did so
many other things that should have been
the last straw but it was really the
cheating that like mean at the last
straw and it took me a while to get over
him but then I saw her and she was
talking about this guy that I knew
already that was gonna be the one and I
was like not these [ __ ] guys you have
no way damn who is this lady I'm like
asking for only invited our sleepover
yellower yeah she ended up becoming like
when I first started going to her was
like 2010 and I would just go once or
twice a year and um she like was just a
small like was in this small little
thing that sold like crystals and stuff
and baza kinda yeah and um I don't even
remember how I found it oh yeah cuz they
had a tea room in there and I was just
checking out their tea room because I've
never been to one before and then they
had like a psychic in the bag and I go
pray but yeah so she ended up being like
a celebrity psychic like she became like
very successful and she recently
laundering his expensive true yeah I
think she is she give you an old-school
defensive now maybe so you see her I
haven't seen her in like two three years
but you know that Steve like we could
get married long enough that it came
true yeah mmm and she's met him - told
you [ __ ] yeah what do you say about her
um he he likes her he was like oh she's
like very positive like
he like gets good vibes off people he
let her read him no he's just like I
don't I think he's kind of closed off to
that stuff yeah I think I'm kind of
closed off too but then I kind of still
want to do but I'm kind it's look was
off to it yeah yeah we wouldn't have
hurt I was like can you not tell me yeah
just take it with a grain of salt and
like take it like as entertainment and
then if something like happens from it
you're like oh wow that's crazy like it
can't I guess I put all your eggs in it
I'm afraid of like being like that is so
it is actually true and I'm gonna live
my life by what this person says I'm
scared cuz I feel myself easily like
slipping into that getting crazy now
yeah like a cellphone I went to remember
how he told me like you need to start
hosting shows literally like a week
later is when I got a call from
machinima saying hey we want to give you
your own live show dang Oh what the [ __ ]
and that was at the beginning of my
streaming career and like you know it's
crazy to like I'm saying all of this but
cuz I started like thinking to myself
and I'm like I am a strong believer of
destiny like I do believe that anything
that's meant to happen it will find a
way to make it happen like everything
that we experience in life and
everyone's journey it might be different
like it's not gonna be like exactly
exactly calculated to the tee of what
you're gonna do I don't think it's that
crazy but I do believe that major events
in your life that happened it's because
they were gonna happen they're meant to
happen I couldn't hate that though
because then it's like some people have
the shittiest [ __ ] lives and it's
just like well that was this man you had
no option I think there's free will yeah
yeah I mean I think there is enough to
like sway it like I'm saying you can go
this way you can go this way yeah isn't
like some people just get like they're
like in [ __ ] like slave you know
prostitution and all that [ __ ] and they
just die and I'm like was that their
destiny [ __ ] that you've used to have a
dream like about this street that he had
never seen before where he was in his
30s and he died in the dream like he got
shot at gunpoint and he used to have
that dream over and over again since he
was 12 oh my god and until until instant
he moved and he saw that Street oh and
so he had he had the dream at first when
he was in Virginia and then when he
moved to California he saw that Street
it's in San Diego and he kept having
those dreams throughout his entire life
and he told me about them and he's like
he was in a limo and like there it was
almost like he was like some sort of
like it was you he was inside but yeah
whatever walk down that Street with him
this like this thing happened that I
stopped him from going too and we think
that that might have liked it he stopped
talking the dreams after that and then
he became the age that he was in the
dream and in it didn't happen obviously
but like there was this one event that I
feel like could have been a catalyst to
him going going yeah which I won't talk
about here but yeah it's pretty nuts
like we had a friend that was like oh
yeah you definitely would have been dead
if you went to it yeah yeah that's crazy
because he knows like some FBI people is
crazy yeah but anyway I hope you enjoyed
this episode we thought we'd try
something a little different today and
my mood let us know how like how you
deal with loss and all the stuff cuz I'm
sure there's a lot of people in the
comments that can relate and you have
different stories than we do and we love
that we love reading all of that so oh
yeah tell us your your supernatural
stories because I really want to read
that that stuff yes I don't comment much
but I'm always kind of scrolling through
and reading it so I love to read that so
yeah we'd be snooping on that if I and
if I ever die I'm gonna happy hunt you
guys gonna be great
let us know if we should have a
sleepover too and have like true don't
really need to have that happen we're
like real close oh I know I'm ready for
it
subscribe like all that stuff review and
we'll see check out our merch to buy
imagine if she tells me you're gonna be
pregnant like [ __ ] you